[Music]
all right travel costs are going up and
experts aren't predicting a decrease
anytime soon bummer and now a possible
bidding war over discount carrier spirit
airlines which also doesn't mean good
news for us customers heather mills
explains
spirit is known as the no frills airline
cheap tickets where you pay a la carte
for things like bags including carry-ons
and even snacks a merger would mean
higher costs for everyone
historically we've seen when airlines
merge prices do go up for consumers
right now it's a battle for spirit
airlines both frontier and jetblue vying
to buy the low-cost carrier for billions
clint henderson with the points guy says
get ready to dig deeper into your
pockets if a spirit merger happens
you're going to have less competition in
the space and that usually means higher
ticket prices probably not great news
for consumers net net but there's a
chance it might not even get approved
neither one of these mergers but if
there is a winner
you're looking at two partnerships with
very different end results they will be
two different beasts if it's a if it's a
frontier merger it's going after budget
travelers if it's a jet blue merger it's
more business travelers and higher end
consumers either merger could create the
nation's fifth largest airline creating
less competition in the market which is
where the justice department and
antitrust regulators could step in if
you're eliminating the cheapest route
the cheapest tickets available in the
market all of a sudden not only is that
bargain basement fair gone but the other
airlines can also raise their prices
because if they're not competing against
spirit they can raise prices even higher
and as far as destinations go frontier
offers a lot of roots on the west coast
so combining with spirits network along
the east coast and the caribbean it
would expand its portfolio jetblue
strength on the east coast including
florida would mean much more overlap
with spirit one of the big takeaways for
consumers the concern that the merger
would eliminate the cheap airfare that
spirit is known for at a time when
experts say ticket prices are already
going up about seven percent a month
heather mills live local now